what are those traits that
you see as the best for a producer like
what
it's just i'm sure a different hat so to
speak than acting and
well the the only thing i saw relatable
was people skills as an actor you
definitely have people skills and as a
producer you need them
because you're calling in a lot of
favors and you know you have to be a
social person who can relate to many
different types of people from many
different
backgrounds and different fields and i
felt that i had that initially
just because i'm a charming guy
sometimes
so
that was the first step because i felt
that i could approach people talk to
them
um
the other thing is that i'm latino and
you can't tell a latino no
you can't do that um my friend who
crashed to parties was latino so
you couldn't tell him no brian crashed
the party because you couldn't tell him
he couldn't go to the party and for
myself i felt that i could do this movie
because people were telling me i
couldn't so you can't tell me no
and i think that's why latinos created
that phrase si se puede yes we can
because it's true so i felt that that
was the second thing i had is where and
it's also an american trait you know i
think there was a documentary where they
said that americans don't succeed in
much in terms of
education but when it comes to
confidence
we're number one
and latinos have that same
sort of number one confidence level
and
so that was
the two things that i ran with on this
project
was my confidence and
people skills